national football league announcing as
expected as reported for weeks if not
months the nfl's new tv deals reportedly
10 billion
per year they get tacked on to the end
of the existing deals for the most part
it's a continuation
there are some new tweaks shireen but
the bottom line is significant money for
the nfl and significant certainty for
the legacy networks that may be
frankly obsolete 10 years from now sorry
as part of the nbc family but this may
be the last deal that goes to nbc cbs
abc fox by the time we get to the next
deal it may be amazon youtube netflix
hulu taking over these contracts and
taking over the broadcasting world
and we already see mike amazon taking
over the thursday night package coming
up this season or when the next tv
package takes effect they'll have the
thirsty night deal so already seeing
that move being made but yeah it's going
to be whoever forks over the most money
i am curious what some of these players
think who are getting squeezed right now
are they happy about this because they
see potential money down the road are
they mad right now because they see the
owners getting even more billions than
what they were getting while they're
getting squeezed this year with the
lower salary cap
yeah and uh look the bottom line is the
nfl is going to continue to make a ton
of money going forward with the gambling
proliferation
the games will be more valuable the
league will be more valuable the teams
will be more valuable i had an owner
tell me late in the 2020 season that
before too long these teams are going to
be worth 10 billion each not just the
cowboys all teams even the teams that
currently are worth maybe 2 billion
that's where this is moving as the nfl
continues to be the one property that
can gather live eyeballs the audience
fractures people watch things on a binge
basis how many shows really at this
point shireen do people feel compelled
to stop everything they're doing and
watch
as they're broadcast for the first time
the nfl is the only entity that can do
that and as more types of betting are
available specifically in game betting
and it is coming you have to watch the
game live or there's no way to get in on
the action
yeah and you saw the oprah interview
which was touted as everyone watched the
oprah interview and then you compared to
the nfl season and it didn't it didn't
compare there is no comparison the nfl
rules the tv world right now mike and it
gets the most eyeballs of anything even
when the numbers fall we've seen it in
years when when the numbers have fallen
but it's still better than anything else
on tv right now so it does rule the tv
world mike
the details are fairly simple because
there isn't much in the way of change
nbc keeps sunday night football espn
will have monday night football i
believe when the dust settles it will be
espn with some abc simulcasts there will
be multiple weeks with two games not
just week one with the second game on
abc the first game on espn second game
abc presumably and espn and later in the
year there'll be two games that are
scheduled and they'll determine the
order later in the year with the better
game going late and the lesser game
going early i think that's where it's
moving as the nfl begins the process of
carving out more windows that's the
other thing to watch as we move forward
two games on monday tuesday night
football wednesday night football to go
with thursday night football more
windows more opportunities for people to
cluster around one game and bet on the
things that happen as the games are
unfolding the sunday packages in the
afternoon are the same the nfc package
on cbs or on fox excuse me it was on cbs
back when we were kids sharing but not
anymore the afc package on cbs the nfc
package a little more valuable because
of the dallas cowboys plain and simple
and that thursday night package it
starts in 2023 on amazon because fox
already has bought it through 2022
none of the broadcast networks wanted it
you know it gives you the power to own a
night on the prime time schedule it
ultimately got to the point where it
wasn't worth it because you had to pay
the nfl premium you only had a certain
number of games i think it was 10 that
actually were on the three letter
network the other games were exclusive
to nfl network you had to pay for the
production costs in the entirety and
after it cycled through cbs then cbs
sharing with nbc then fox took the whole
thing over the major network said the
hell with this it's too expensive amazon
though this is a great opportunity for
them
to deepen the relationship with the
league and to show what they can do and
here's where amazon has value and i know
that a lot of people are going to
complain because they don't have amazon
prime well you're going to have to get
amazon prime if you don't have it it's
99 bucks a year they're probably going
to jack up the price you get all sorts
of video you get audio you get quick
delivery of all the stuff you buy not
that it's free but if you want to see
those thursday night games and you don't
live in the markets
because i'm sure that the games will be
broadcast on free tv in the markets for
the teams involved you're going to have
to get amazon prime but here's the key
sharing
and someone said someone explained this
to me several years ago when amazon
started to emerge as a player for these
rights
anytime you watch
an amazon prime game because you will
have an amazon prime account and you
will have a browsing history and you
will have a purchase history through
your amazon prime account what will
happen is not only will you be
targeted with ads based upon your buying
habits and your
your overall
net worth and earning potential based
upon what you buy and how often you buy
it
for example
brands like ferrari never are gonna buy
an ad for a nationally televised game
because a small fraction of the audience
is ever even going to be in a position
to consider buying one but
on amazon prime
they can they will know
all the people who have browsed ferraris
all the people who seem to have the
money to buy a ferrari and they'll get
highly concentrated targeted ads and
beyond that shereen let's say that you
buy i for me i buy my shaving cream
three tubes at a time three cans at a
time big cans of edge free advertising
for edge sensitive skin orange top i get
three cans at a time and what it'll do
and i get it on amazon and what will
happen
i'll get a commercial
for edge shaving cream and there'll be a
button that i can press
to reorder my edge shaving cream just
like that transaction done during the
commercial that's where the value is to
amazon
yeah no question mike and and we're
going to begin to see that and it'll be
interesting to see where this
relationship goes and we saw amazon had
the the one game last year a saturday
game the cardinals and i can't remember
who the cardinals were playing i do
remember it was the cardinals and i
didn't even realize i had amazon prime
but i didn't realize i had like i never
watched amazon prime on on tv and
got it like i was like oh i have this
and and watch the game but there's going
to be a lot of that where i think it's
going to be really valuable for for
amazon because i think people are going
to go get it they're going to see it as
a great value because you can order
stuff on amazon and you can go watch nfl
games oh by the way so i think this is a
great move by amazon and this i think
this relationship mike is only going to
grow
and i don't want to do any free
advertising here for amazon and to the
extent that amazon prime has a video
service it competes with peacock but
here's the reality six seven years ago
my wife told me about amazon prime and
she got it because it allowed her to get
the stuff that she ordered quickly and
it had special deals and exactly
priority stuff and free shipping and i
started poking around it's like you got
all these shows you can watch look what
i didn't know anything about it all
these movies all these shows that are on
amazon prime included in the price and
again it's an annual fee and it's
probably more than 99 bucks a year now
and if it isn't it will be
but uh that that's where it's moving and
another thing to keep in mind
when this
deal ends
and amazon and youtube and the other
major digital companies swoop in i think
what could happen
you could see a situation where the
digital companies buy an entire window
and they assume the streaming rights for
that window and then they sell directly
to
the broadcast networks the packages that
will allow the games to be televised as
they normally have so the digital
companies that buy the global rights
will become the middle people for
the end result with nbc cbs abc fox to
the extent that those networks even
still exist 10 years from now i mean the
world has changed look at the focus that
nbc is putting on peacock we're on
peacock streaming you can watch it live
you can watch it whenever and you start
looking around peacock there's so much
stuff there you don't need any other
streaming service you don't need amazon
prom except during football season so
you can watch the thursday night games
starting in 2023 but that that i mean
the world has changed dramatically over
the past 20 years
it's it's almost logarithmic like the
earthquake scale i think is i think it's
going to change faster and faster and
faster as we get deeper and deeper into
this decade and by the end of the decade
it will be it'll be dramatically
different than it is now
and here's the real question mike will
you and i who by the way right now are
not the same age but will be in a couple
months from now will we still
[Laughter]
i plan on dying with my boots on and
there's no reason to retire there's no
reason to stop uh and so i'm gonna work
until the day that i drop dead maybe
during the show that would make for a
highly viewable youtube clip if i were
to drop dead
during the broadcast uh one last thing
the commissioner said in a conference
call today that the league is going to
take up the question of the 17-game
season at the annual meetings that will
be held virtually march 30 and 31 i'm
told it's it's a done deal they're doing
the 17 games they wanted to get these tv
contracts in place so they know what
they'd get paid for the 17 games now
that they do the 17 games will happen
the only issue that was left was whether
to have three preseason games or
to give to the union when you go to 18.
so you stick with three preseason games
so when it's time to go to 18 and to 18
they will go
that's when you say hey by the way we'll
go to two preseason games if you go to
two now you got nothing to give them so
uh 17 and three it's been 20 for years
when we were kid shireen it was 14 and
6. 78 it became 16 and 4. now it's going
to be 17-3 eventually it'll be 18-2 and
i think to expand the inventory beyond
that what will happen is i believe
they'll expand the league at some point
and hopefully we'll be alive for that to
happen because that's probably
i'd say 10 to 15 years away but don't be
surprised because the nfl does these
things you know they plant the seeds
they talk about it it comes up they deny
it right
i think at some point in the next two or
three years once the gambling really
takes off they're going to realize
more teams equals more games equals more
money and there will be more teams uh in
the nfl uh and sharing there's enough
quarterbacks now to justify a few years
ago it never would have worked now
there's enough quarterbacks that's the
key to have 34 or 36 teams if they do
that
and i'll be interested too mike are we
ever going to have a spring season to
take off especially when gambling comes
in and will the xfl come back will
people be interested in this game year
round whether it's the nfl or another
league that will be interesting to see
and let me tell you you know if i had
the money to do it if i had the money
and i wanted to buy an nfl team and they
wouldn't let me in the club i would
create a minor league that played on
tuesday and wednesday nights that's why
the nfl better start thinking about
finding ways to put games on tuesday and
wednesday nights because those nights
are screaming out and i've been saying
this for the past three years with the
aaf and the xfl i don't care about
spring football and i don't know that
gambling is going to make me care about
spring football i want football during
football season drop those games on
tuesday and wednesday night and i really
do believe if the nfl ever thought
someone was going to do that you know
would be like when they did the
broadcast of foxes in living color
during halftime live of a super bowl
that's what woke the nfl up and got the
nfl to start having real halftime shows
during the super bowl if someone would
drop a competitive league on tuesday and
wednesday nights it wouldn't be more
than a year or two that the nfl would
would definitely put games on tuesday
nights but that's where it's all going
more windows more games more inventory
more opportunities for you to watch on
tv
pick up your cell phone device and wager
a little bit here a little bit there a
little bit here a little bit there as
the game unfolds and the one thing they
have to solve technologically when you
turn on your tv you want to be able to
see what's happening in the stadium as
it's happening and right now shireen is
in texas i'm in west virginia it's all
flowing through connecticut and i can
see my hand there is no lag because i
can see the monitor below me and there
is no lag between my hand a little a
little bit a little bit of a lag and uh
they'll get to the point where there's
none everything you see at home is going
to be what's coming from the state and
when they do that that's when everything
explodes sharing
well i need you to come fix my monitor
mike because i can't see anything right
now the first time i've been without a
monitor so
um well i then then i won't use any of
the hand gestures that are among the
favorites thank you
of chris sims uh or i or and i won't be
eating any hamburgers that i drop onto
the floor at the airport
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports